[Аеропракт]
Ukraїner
Експедиція
1979-го року, за температури -26
я вперше відірвався від землі
і я дуже добре пам'ятаю цей момент
Незабутні відчуття цієї легкості, волі, польоту...
Мрія мати своє підприємство, свою фірму була ще в радянський час,
але тоді вона була нездійсненна
[Полісся. Наливайківка]
Спочатку, знаєте, я був справжньою радянською людиною:
батько мій комуністом був ще з довоєнних часів
Мене виховували за принципом, що продавати на базарі вишні зі свого саду — це ганьба!
Приватний бізнес — це ніби гріх такий
Мене звати Яковлєв Юрій
Я — головний конструктор підприємства «Аеропракт»,
яке проектує, виготовляє та продає легкі двомісні літаки
Історія походження назви «Аеропракт» сягає 1974 року,
коли випускник Харківського авіаційного інституту (ХАІ),
який народився і ріс у містечку Нова Водолага під Харковом
Він закінчив ХАІ, і в 1974 році, переїхавши із Харкова в Куйбишев,
він організував отаке молодіжне конструкторське бюро «Аеропракт»
Через 4 роки — в 1978 році
і я переїхав зі свого маленького шахтарського поселення в російській частині Донбасу
Я переїхав для того аби вступити в Куйбишівський авіаційний інститут
І там за щасливим збігом в тому ж році я зустрів цей клуб «Аеропракт»
і мого наставника — Василя Мірошника
[Наддніпрянщина. Київ
Виробництво компанії «Аеропракт»]
Це ділянка, де складаються металеві агрегати наших літаків
Всі деталі виготовляються із американського матеріалу —
спеціальний алюмінієвий сплав для авіації
Це початок складання фюзеляжу літака «А-22»,
а це перед вами крила, які вже готові до фарбування
Вони обтягнуті спеціальною синтетичною тканиною,
яка є дуже міцною і виготовляється у Франції
Тут фюзеляж літака, який мене привів до Києва
Це — «Аеропракт-8»
Я почав виготовляти його ще студентом у 1981 році, коли мені було 20 років,
а закінчив роботу над ним у 1984 році
1985 року в Києві був зліт любительської авіації
Тоді це було під егідою Міністерства авіаційної промисловості Радянського Союзу
Літак, який я привіз, посів там перше місце,
завдяки чому мене запросили працювати в КБ «Антонова», а я погодився!
А через рік — у 1986 році — я організував уже київський «Аеропракт»
Кішконенависник такий [грайливо]
Ну, що це таке? Га?
У мене була можливість поїхати в КБ Сухого,
втім я радий, що не поїхав до Москви,
Адже немає жодного успішного проекту малої авіації  Росії,
тим більше у Москві!
Жовтий літак — «Аеропракт-22». Він продається найбільше
Їх виготовлено близько 950-ти
Розпочали їх серійно випускати у 1998 році
Цей літак свого часу створили ми,
а згодом цей літак створив нашу фірму
Коли тут почалися якісь кооперативи,
я не сприймав цього, відштовхував, бо ж як?
Ідея була така: я будуватиму кар'єру на «Антонова»,
і я це успішно й робив...
так успішно, що мені запропонували очолити бригаду
Але двоє хлопців з «Антонова» організували кооператив,
вони на замовлення виготовили кілька мотодельтапланів,
і в них все почало з'являтися:
вони працювали весь час, хоч і у маленькому приміщенні,
а ми тільки вечорами, і не щодня
І ми їм заздрили білою заздрістю,
а тому вирішили йти таким же шляхом
Щоправда, були сумніви,
адже я чув історії багатьох провідних конструкторів,
коли їм керівництво у певний момент казало:
«Стоп! Вибирай: або моделювання, або ж ти йдеш далі»
У 1980-х ми подумали, що швидше зможемо виготовляти літаки,
якщо робитимемо це за кошти, матимемо якийсь прибуток
На початку 1990-х ми виживали,
брали різні підробітки: ремонтували планери...
Робили все, що тільки могли, аби заробляти кошти
Навіть був такий період, коли ми мали автомобіль DAF — досить великий,
тож ми возили продукти для одного із перший приватних ресторанів на Подолі — «Запоріжжя»,
возили із Бориспільського аеропорту,
адже всі продукти тоді доставляли із Австрії чи звідкись ще:
живі омари чи інші делікатеси,
а ми їх возили своїм автомобілем
Це допомагало нам підтримувати діяльність нашого підприємства
Це — перший серійний літак,
«Аеропракт-20»
Його виготовили у 1993 році,
а прототип цього літака літав ще у 1991 році
Він дещо відрізнявся,
хоч прототип став першим літаком, який нам вдалось продати
Продали його у 1993 році до Угорщини
Це був перший, а тому дуже важливий для нас, продаж
«Аеропракт-20» став першим сертифікованим літаком в Україні,
а саме у 2000 році ми стали першопрохідцями сертифікації
До того жодна фірма не мала сертифікату типу
Ми з партнером вийшли з КБ «Антонова»,
і принесли звідти класичні металеві конструкції
Так, ми багато навчилися на «Антонова»,
але ми і багато навчилися за останні вже майже 30 років,
а тому ми достатньо вдосконалили металеві конструкції
Варто визнати, що потреба у наших літаках досить низька
Це дуже хороша, але все ж іграшка,
а без іграшок наш світ був би дуже сірим
Зокрема, коли мене запитують про практичне застосування цих літаків,
я відповідаю, що десь таке ж, як і у гідроциклів
Першу золоту медаль ми виграли на нашому першому літаку,
який виготовили ще у 1993 році, він ще мав інший двигун
Ми на ньому поїхали на змагання, бо не встигли завершити нову спортивну модель,
тому їхали скоріше для того, аби потренуватися
Так добре потренувалися, що здобули першість
Наші конкуренти трішки нам заздрять
і, здається, не завжди по-доброму, бо у них нема таких можливостей
Щоб спортсмен мав змогу звернутися до фірми,
яка спеціально під нього здатна зробити літак,
то це вже рівень «Формули-1»
Я не вважаю своїх колег конкурентами
Головний конкурент міститься в нас самих — це наша лінь
Тут була тільки злітна смуга
Колись був якийсь аеродром, напевне, бо тут було господарство для удобрювання полів
Купили цю ділянку зі смугою, відновили її
[Тимофій Яковлєв
пілот клубу «Аеропракт»]
і побудували ангар із залом
Коли був завод спочатку, то вони літали на «Чайці»,
але, як мені відомо, їх почали звідти витісняти
Мій батько каже, що завдяки тому, що їх звідти вигнали, вони створили власний аеродром
Здавалося б: тут тепло, все обладнано, близько...
А коли ти приїздиш на «Чайку», а кажуть, що не можна літати, бо парашутисти стрибають
— А коли можна? — питаю
— Ну, от ті літаки полетять...
Полетіли
— Не можна літати, бо забагато літаків літає
(аж цілих три!)
— Ну, зателефонуй начальнику, може він дозволить...
Телефоную
— Володимире Михайловичу, ну як же так?
— Ну, дай слухавку!
— Хай літають
І ми втішені побігли годин 6 літати, якраз кілька польотів, хоч всім не вистачило часу,
тож незадоволені поїхали додому
І очевидно, що опісля цього, коли отримуєш свободу,
хоч там і холодно, і незручно, і літаки за ангаром стоять,
зате ти літаєш, коли тобі заманеться
І це клас! Хоч в цьому сенсі ти хоч і бідний, зате вільний!
Коли на змаганнях, де ми виграли, двічі грав наш державний Гімн,
то це для мене було дуже зворушливо
Ми виготовляємо наші літаки під маркою «Виготовлено в Україні»
Ми працюємо над репутацією нашої країни
Я гордий, що живу тут, що мої діти тут народилися,
а ще що саме зараз ми відстоюємо свою незалежність,
а я якраз в правильному місці, в правильний час!